Oh, my doctor told me not to punch so many people.
Yeah. Well I mean, that goes without saying.
It's probably bad for everyone if you do that,
but I like the pick. I like it.
Yeah. I'd watch a dark HBO series about that.
Yeah. I'd watch it.
Just to be clear, did I just accidentally
pitch an episode of Rick and Morty?
Tom, what is a teen TV character
you'd like to see as a grownup?
Well my friends, if we're talking about teen TV
characters that we want to
see as grownups, pardon me.
Which we are.
And we are.
Are we interrupting your lunch?
I'm sorry. What happened?
I have a mint. Friends, if we're talking about
teen TV characters that we want to see growing up,
I want to paint you a picture. So,
imagine that you write for a website.
Okay. I'm imagining it.
Crazy. Okay. So, you get sent out on a story.
It turns out there's this charismatic dude
who's living in the middle of the forest,
let's say in Southern Oregon somewhere,
with a small group of people who they've sort of,
I don't know. They've started orbiting him. They
all believe in what he's saying. They say that
he's saying some great things and nobody can
quite figure out what it is that he's preaching.
So, you get sent down to go and talk to this dude
and it turns out the guy that you meet, he's got
a big, old, man bun. He's living in this peaceful,
sort of idyllic, natural community. He says
his name is Ma-Ti and that 30 years ago,
the spirit of the planet Earth, Gaia, came
to him and four other people and said that
they were responsible for taking
care of the planet from now on.
That they were the guardians, the stewards of
the planet and sometimes Mother Earth sounded
like the lady from The View and sometimes she
sounded like Lois Lane from the Superman movies.
But what really mattered was that she gave
everybody jewelry that let them control
some aspect of the natural experience and that
he was given the ability to control the hearts
and minds of men and animals. And that as a result
of that, he now deserves to be in charge of all of
these people. And then you say, "Well, that's
really interesting. I'm going to go," and he's
like, "Nah, stay." And you're like, "No. Really.
I got to go," and then he's like, "No. Stay."
And all of a sudden you feel compelled
to stick around the community
because I think you know something
about me, I'm fascinated by
stories about characters who are granted
these fantastic abilities and what that
would do to them later on down the road or
these phenomenal experiences. We talked about
It's A Wonderful Life a while ago and how I don't
think that George wound up being probably a very
good person after he had this experience where the
actual literal God said, "You're a great dude."
And I would be further fascinated to learn what
happened, on that same note, I would be amazed
to find out what happened to the Planeteers after
the whole Captain Planet thing was over. Clearly
they didn't win, right? The planet's still
dying at a faster pace than it was 30 years-
Worse than ever, some might say.
So bad, right?
It's bad. Yeah.
It's not great. So, I would love to find out
what happened to these five children who were
given control of the elements and then told that
they were responsible for fixing the planet.
Yeah because what have they been up
to for the past couple of decades?
Yeah, right. Exactly.
Was it nothing?
Maybe it was nothing. Maybe it was
fat nothing. Yeah. We don't know.
Right. Maybe they were
actively doing damage? Yeah.
Probably had to get their rings
resized because they've clearly all-
Yeah, as they grew. Yeah.
Yeah.
You would hope. Yeah.
Some of them are like,
"I just don't like this style anymore."
They just stopped wearing their rings.
It's kind of bulky. They're bulky rings. I mean,
when you look at them, they're bulky
looking and they all wore them-
It makes me look like a jerk. I'm walking around
with, yeah. No. You're an adult, unmarried man-
They go to college. They're like,
"But I like my class ring better."
Yeah. That kind of thing. Furthermore, I
don't know. I feel like there are a ton
of unanswered questions in that mythology.
I would just love an exploration of them.
Where's Captain Planet? What's he doing? Because-
Didn't LeVar Burton do Kwame?
He did, yeah. I don't think for the whole
series, but yeah. Yeah. LeVar Burton did Kwame.
For a little while at least, yeah.
So in the recent season of Rick and Morty, they
actually dive into this a bit. Did you see that?
Do they?
Yeah. There's an episode where-
I have not caught up yet.
... Morty falls in love with Planetina. That
is a female version of Captain Planet and
he encounters all of the current adult Planeteers
and they're more like brand managers and they're
not particularly interested in saving the planet
so much as they are in managing Planetina's brand.
It's pretty bleak looking. It's
bleak. I won't spoil it, but
I mean it goes about as well as you think
it would in an episode of Rick and Morty.
So, not great. Yeah.
So, everyone who's watching this video now and
who's seen that episode is probably typing into
the comments about everything that happened in
that episode. So, you could stop now. We know.
We know what happens, but yeah. No. I think that
is a good idea. I think it would be fun to revisit
the Captain Planet idea in 2021 to see the
ways in which they failed and maybe the ways
in which they're trying to succeed. I don't
know. It always seemed weird that Captain
Planet's one weakness was pollution when
that was the thing he was supposed to stop.
Yeah. That was really his one-
Yeah. Right. Was there no allergy medication
he could take to deal with the pollution thing?
I'm here to clean up pollution. Ah! It got on
me. I'm weak now. That's like if you're Batman,
but every time you punch a criminal, you're
like, "Oh no, my one weakness! Criminals!"
My one weakness, punching. Yeah. Oh, my
doctor told me not to punch so many people.
Yeah. Well I mean, that goes without saying.
That's probably bad for everyone if you
do that, but I like the pick. I like it.
Yeah. I'd watch a dark HBO series about that.
Yeah. I'd watch it.
Just to be clear, did I just accidentally pitch an
episode of Rick and Morty? Was that the
plot of an episode of Rick and Morty?
Not entirely. It's not the bulk of
the episode, but yeah. A little bit.
Your Rick and Morty adjacent. Yeah.
I think it's good though. So Nina, what
about you? What's your pick for this topic?
Well, I looked at the article
that we're talking about today and
for a second, I almost picked Gossip Girl, but
I didn't for two reasons. One is that I thought
you would both just leave if I started talking
about Gossip Girl extensively, potentially.
And two, we already know what would happen to
the person who turned out to be Gossip Girl as
an adult because You is a TV show and he just
graduated from cyber-stalking to murder. So,
we already have an answer to that. I mean,
honestly Joe from You is if Dan Humphrey murdered
people because he's just as manipulative
and creepy, but just there's more blood.
So what I ended up picking is we kind of got an
answer to this, but I still think we could do
more with it because the answer is a little
old now, is the cast of Freaks and Geeks.
Yeah. So in 2012, Paul Feig kind of talked
about what would have happened to the characters
after the series ended and I think
he said, "Lindsay would be a lawyer
and eventually Sam would've joined drama,"
and he was like, "Daniel would be in jail."
That tracks.
Yeah. That does track. And so he had
all these answers, but I still think,
I mean we all know Freaks and Geeks. We all love
Freaks and Geeks. One of the best teenage casts in
not television history, history, period. I
mean every person who appeared on that show,
even people who appeared in the background,
like Lizzy Caplan are very famous now.
Rashida Jones. She was a bully for one episode.
Rashida Jones. That's right and so, it's
just like to have... And it was also canceled
way before its time and it's canceled
what? It's like, Lindsay's getting on the-
On the bus to go see-
Right. She's going to go follow
the Dead around the country and-
Busy Philipps.
Right and so it's just not only do I think I
want to see all these people work together again,
especially with Paul Feig because I love Paul
Feig so much, but just I think that it would be
fascinating to find out what actually happened
to them. I mean, I would like to stick with
James Franco's Daniel being in jail. I
don't think you can improve upon that.
He doesn't have to show up. He doesn't
have to. He doesn't have to be there.
No and that would be fine, but-
Hey guys, gather around, I got
another letter from Daniel!
He's still in prison. Yeah.
He's still in prison.
Oh, no.
But I want to see what happened
to Jason Segel's sweet,
doofy, Nick. Yeah. I want to see what happened-
Does he ever learn to play the
drums better? Probably not.
Right and in terms of the alternate universe
thing I touched on with Gossip Girl and You, I'm
curious, which Linda Cardellini do we
think Lindsay Weir is? Do we think that
she is the Dead to Me Linda Cardellini? Do
we think that she is the knife wielding,
A Simple Favor, Linda Cardellini? Do we think
that she's the Legally Blonde Me Linda Cardellini?
There's a lot of options. Do we think she's the
MCU Linda Cardellini? There's so many places.
So that was going to be my last thing is, does
she just become Velma and everything takes a
very weird shift? But yeah. I don't think I
need to explain why I want to see the cast of
Freaks and Geeks reunited as adults and hang out
together and show us where they ended up. I don't
think anyone's like, "Why'd she pick that?" I
think we'd all like to see where they ended up.
It would be awesome.
With Judd Apatow and Paul Feig at the helm. Yeah.
It kind of tracks that she left so that
she could go and watch the Grateful Dead
across the country and then turned
into a member of Mystery Inc.
That's as reasonable an origin
story for that group of people.
Exactly.
You spend a summer following the Dead around the
country and then by the end of it, you're like,
"We need to find ghosts and this dog can talk."
Also, on a not that note but something that
occurred to me is, everyone thought like
Busy Philipps' Kim Kelly was the burnout
and Lindsay Weir was the genius, but
in the Gilmore Girls revival, Rory Gilmore, the
wunderkind of Stars Hollow is a huge failure. So,
what if Lindsay Weir is a burnout
and Kim Kelly is running a company
and is a CEO and in charge of everything?
What if we completely defied expectations?
I can see her being like a LuLaRoe
representative that's doing-
I actually could see her bullying
people into letting her run
LuLaRoe. She's like owning the entire company.
I want to see grown up Bill.
I want to see Martin Starr-
Right, yes.
Because Martin Starr grew into a very cool dude.
So cool.
Seems to have.
But Bill is always hunched over. He's
like the turbo nerd. He is the geek-
I didn't mean to focus so much on the freak
side of Freaks and Geeks because the geeks
are so fun and I love Samm Levine. All of these
people, I want to see. They all continued acting-
John Daley's like a screenwriter now,
but he's- Did he grow really tall?
He's really tall. Let him play a
screenwriter. That would be cool.
Yeah, it would be great. I'd love to see it.
Yeah, exactly.
But their dad is, what's his name? Isn't Count Floyd,
right? Are either of you
familiar with what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Yes and then their dad or their mom is Becky
Ann Baker who plays the mom in every TV show.
She's just everyone's mom.
Yeah. Lindsay and what is John Daley's character's
name? It's disappeared from my brain already.
Sam.
Lindsay and Sam. Thank you. Right. Oh, because
I got confused because Neil is the actor's name-
Yeah.
All right. I'm back on track. No, they find
out that Lena Dunham is their half sister.
I was just going to say Hannah Horvath,
half sister. Yeah. Their mom remarried
and their mom doesn't want to
fund their half sister's groovy
New York lifestyle anymore and then
yeah. It all kicks off from there.
What would the adult Freaks and Geeks revival
be called? Haters and losers or something?
Freakier and Geekier.
We can workshop that too. We
have a lot of workshopping to do.
I think that's perfect actually. Freakier
and Geekier. It's just called Reddit.
It's just called, "Oh, my back
hurts," because they're all old now.
That's great. I love it. I would
watch that. Honestly though,
I think we're probably a few
years out from seeing that.
I'm really hoping, yeah.
If tomorrow they announced the Freaks and Geeks
revival on Netflix or Hulu or any of these
streaming services, people would
freak out. They'd lose their minds.
If they did it with Wet Hot American Summer,
why can't they do it with Freaks and Geeks?
Yeah, for sure.
That's all I'm saying
One good thing though to say about that show
that got canceled after only one season is
that you have one perfect season and you
don't have to be like, "Don't watch this
other stuff," when it got bad or I didn't like
it when this character left or whatever. You
just have a perfect little story that
has a beginning, middle, and an end-
So, yeah. A reboot could be very dangerous,
but I think it's enough time has passed and
everyone in that cast is so cool
and talented that they'd be able
to probably whip something and also half
the cast is now professional screenwriters.
John Francis Daley and Jason Segel have
both written a ton of movies. So, yeah.
So, okay. So, I'm going to hop in and talk a
little bit more specifically about the article
that we have on Looper.com, Teen TV Characters We
Want To See As Grownups. So one of them, top one,
Blossom from Blossom. We are kind of seeing her
as a grownup now. She grew up to host Jeopardy.
So, there you go. We could
just move on from that one.
Yeah or she became Amy from The Big Bang Theory.
Right, exactly. A name of a character I
don't know because it's a show I don't watch.
I like that about you.
Bing Bong Theory. Dawson from Dawson's Creek. We
know what happened to him because he was in Don't
Trust the B In Apartment 23. Although James Van
Der Beek, not Dawson, but still, close enough.
And also he became a popular internet meme.
Yeah. Right? Wouldn't that be great if Dawson grew
up and then found out that his face was a meme.
Oh, no. He just lost all of his confidence.
Discovered that the whole world has been
laughing at him for the last 20 years.
For sure.
Steady eating his feelings.
He ballooned up to 400 pounds.
Aw, poor Dawson.
Tia and Tamera from Sister, Sister is a good one.
That's a show I watched and enjoyed as a young man
because I watched everything that was
on TV for the most part at that point.
Same.
Now I know, I think that both of
those actors are still working as
actors today. So, I'm sure if
they announced that tomorrow-
I believe that they are. I think they
probably, I think they do TV movies and stuff.
What if they did a Sister, Sister revival
on Disney Plus and each of them had twins-
Oh, man.
Sister, Sister, Sister, Sister, Sister, Sister.
Wow.
I don't know if America's ready.
That's a lot. Oh, they are. They're both
still acting and they did some, well
they did a reality show. One of
them hosts a talk show. Yeah.
And I think one of them, didn't
they do a movie about witches
called Twitches or something?
Twin witches? I don't know.
You know what? If they didn't,
then they could in the future.
They should now.
Yeah.
Another one on this list, Seth Cohen from The OC,
a show I did not watch, but the
actor who played Seth Cohen-
I did!
... tell us about Seth Cohen from The
OC. I don't know anything about him.
Oh, my first love, Seth Cohen. I'm not
kidding. So he's one of those teens who
he's supposed to be the loser, but he's so
classically handsome that you're like, "Come on."
He's got Andrew Garfield Spider-Man Syndrome.
No and he's also like, "I like comic
books and video games," and I'm like,
"Yeah, everyone likes that
stuff." He starts a comic book
club at school and he gets one member and I'm
like, "That would never happen, ever." But
He's a really funny character. He gets some of
the best lines in the show. Very quick-witted,
very sharp, really good repartee between him
and other characters. A seminal teen character-
There is a movie. I'm sorry to cut you off.
Oh no. It's okay.
There was a movie called The Kid
Detective starring Adam Brody,
in which he plays basically a grownup-
Seth Cohen.
... detective. Seth Cohen. Right. So, I
don't know how much there's overlap between
that character and his character and The Kid
Detective, but The Kid Detective is excellent.
I just hope he didn't grow up into his
character from Ready or Not because
that would be pretty bleak. I like that movie
a whole lot, but yeah. I'm not going to spoil
it here. It's a fun movie, but I hope
he did not grow up into that character.
So, I know I've just run through a
whole bunch of characters and one of
them that's on this list is Steve Urkel. Who
wouldn't want to see a grownup Steve Urkel?
Me.
Anyway, the character I think
has the most potential here
is Paige Jennings from The Americans.
Have you guys watched The Americans?
Mm-mm
Not all the way through, but I
have seen Paige a whole bunch
and I also live on the internet. So, I
know what happens at the end of the series.
Right. So I'm going to spoil it for you, Tom.
Sorry, not sorry. It's been on for a long time.
I had my chance.
So, Paige is the daughter of these two Soviet
spies who are undercover in America and eventually
she figures out that her parents are spies and she
joins them and becomes a spy as well. Yeah and so,
it ends with them leaving the country to go back
to Russia and Paige is going to go with them,
but she's never even been to Russia. So, she bails
on them at the Canadian border and leaves and
stays in America and we don't know what happens to
her at the end. So, the last shot of the show are
the two parents back in Russia basically wondering
what's going on with their kids back in America
and we don't know what's going on. And so, their
son is basically going to be, he's fine. Well,
not fine. I mean, his parents abandoned him, but
he's innocent, but Paige is a fugitive spy. So-
She's been drawn into the fold. Right.
Yeah. It would be amazing to see a follow-up
series to see what Paige has been up to and
what she's gotten up to.
They're reviving Dexter, which
notoriously people hated
by the end and so, they've-
Didn't The Americans receive
universal acclaim for the finale?
Yes.
I remember the finale was on every year on
best of list that year. Everyone loved it-
It was one of the few shows that was
basically amazing from beginning to end.
Because it was what? Four or five
seasons? It was not particularly long.
Yeah. Something like that. So, it's
definitely something that you could
get it. I mean, I've just ruined the
entire ending. So, I'm sorry. But yeah,
I would love to see what Paige is up to as an
adult and just see how she's getting along,
especially since the Soviet Union
collapses. She's here in America,
she has to take on an assumed identity even though
she was born and raised in America. And so, what
she's had to deal with since then. Did she go
to work for American Intelligence eventually?
When is the original plot set?
It's in the '80s.
It's in the '80s. Oh. Okay. So,
she'd have to navigate the '90s
and the turn of the next century.
Oh, that's cool. I would watch that.
Yeah and you see her wearing slap bracelets and
that's got the microfiche in it or something.
Maybe she could grow up and fight Sydney Bristow,
even though their ages don't line up at all.
Sure. I can see the alias crossover
you never knew you needed.
Yeah. Exactly.
Yeah. Perfect. I love it.
You had made a combination,
slap bracelet, microfiche.
Thanks for watching. Please
hit like and subscribe. Bye.